welcome back to the iced coffee hour
this is humphrey yang and so far the
podcast has made two hundred and nine
thousand dollars oh my gosh wow you're
the closest to actual guests we've ever
received oh yeah incredible yeah 213
332 dollars yeah i almost said 212. but
i had watched that one that you did last
last week with the billionaire the
billionaire son yeah yeah what's his
name bobby misner yes bobby and it was
203 so it's like i'm going to go in
there with like 209. it's fantastic yeah
you're a podcast fan yeah i watch them
not all of them yeah but i watch a lot
of them well thank you so much for
coming on the uh the iced coffee hour
we're confronting a tick-tock finance
guru
yes you got 3.3 million followers on
tick tock uh you're a financial advisor
as well i used to be merrill lynch nice
and how did you get started tell us a
bit about your journey how did you go
from financial advisor to tick-tock
finance guru how far do you want me go
like
all the way all the way yeah so i was
born in the bay area redwood city that's
the name of the city but uh i'll just
skip forward to the financial advisory
part
i graduated from college with a finance
degree and from loyola marymount
university down in la
and um
i did a tech job for like a year like a
video game job like customer support
um and then what i did was i wanted to
always try my hand in finance because i
had the finance degree and i felt like
for some reason that my dad would like
it because he's very chinese it's like
want to prove to my dad that i can do it
and so i became a financial advisor for
a year i didn't really like it i didn't
do a good job
and i left after a year and then i went
back to tech so i went to into mobile
video games and i've always had this
like dual passion of like video games
and finance and then also just like
getting better at things or like growing
things
and so i thought growing social media
was always pretty fun and i've always
watched youtube like from a really young
age i was watching youtube like when it
first came out in 2007 2008 i was
watching a lot of it and so basically i
was doing my mobile video game job i'd
come across like an mkbhd video i'd come
across a casey neistat video then i
started watching some graham stefan
videos
and uh that's kind of how i got started
with the whole content thing in 2019
i made three youtube videos just to test
in the summer i was kind of bored i was
trying to figure out what i wanted to do
next
and uh
it didn't do that well
no surprise there's no no no followers
there but
at the end of 2019 i looked on tick tock
and i searched for the hashtag personal
finance and there was none there were
like no videos there was like one guy
making stock videos and i was like okay
this is my opportunity i've been
listening to a lot of naval ravikont and
he was like you want to be first and
you're like you want to scale with media
and so that's when i started i made like
a commitment to make 30 tick tock videos
in 30 days and by the end of 30 days i
think i had like 120 000 followers did
you really yeah
because you can make a really bad video
like what is credit and i was
no camera presence
bad script bad lighting worst lighting
like the worst lighting possible and it
would get like 20 000 views
and for a new account getting 20 000
views on a what is credit video i was
stoked i was like all right let's try
this out let's try this out and uh i
just stuck with the 30 days i got to 60
days then i got to 90 and it's like i
might as well push for 100.
and then after 100 it's like i can't
stop now yeah and it was 2020 it was a
pandemic i got nothing to do and i ended
the streak at like 262 days
of a tick tock every day and i don't
know if you remember we talked yeah in
like
april or may of 2020 i called into the
gram stefan show had like 300 400 000
subscribers at the time followers at the
time and uh yeah
like that's kind of the story why'd you
break your screen cool i had a million
followers and i was like i don't know
what like why am i still keeping the
streak alive i didn't really know what
to do next and so that's kind of why i
did it were you making any money
throughout that process yeah i think
when i called you on the graham stefan
show i had made
at that moment like four thousand
dollars and i had four hundred thousand
followers on tick tock and i remember we
us we were talking about some brand
deals and stuff and my first brand deal
offered me like two thousand dollars for
a post and i was like super stoked yeah
that was awesome but for a really long
time i just didn't take any sponsors on
the tick tock channel yeah and still i'm
kind of not against sponsors but i don't
take that many sponsorships
and so to answer your question i think
in 2020 i made like nineteen thousand
dollars off of content how else were you
making money though because you probably
have expenses rent mortgage what were
you doing uh so i was an e-commerce
consultant okay so between my tech job i
left my tech job in 2016
i started my own e-commerce business
basically selling posters and that i
grew that pretty substantially but then
i was became a consultant for other
types of e-commerce businesses so i was
supplementing my income with that and i
also lived at home and i still live at
home actually so i'm i live at home with
my parents did you mention that on the
gram stefan show did you i think i did
okay yeah and i think yeah
so i am 34 years old
and
because i still live at home but my
dad's gone nine months out of the year
okay and it's only him
so basically i have the house to myself
i haven't really felt the need to move
out yet
but i want to this year because i'm
getting a little bit bored at home and i
get kind of complacent and i get kind of
in the same routine
and so far i think this year i've kind
of realized like it's not really making
me happy anymore to stay at home and i'd
rather just spend the money to move out
somewhere it's a very u.s thing i think
to move out really quickly it seems like
everywhere other than the us like it's
customary to live at home
almost until like you get married and at
which point you you get your own place
yeah and i did move out uh at the age of
like 20
28 for a year i lived in the city san
francisco
and i had an okay time but i would still
drive down to like my hometown and go to
all my favorite like my coffee shops and
my favorite restaurants and my gym down
there
and i just felt like i'd never like
experienced the city life i was just
kind of commuting from the city back to
my own hometown so i was like why am i
even doing this yeah
and i was paying like 2k a month in rent
and i thought it was okay but i wasn't
really like living my best life because
i had a couple roommates they're great
roommates but
um
at some point i was just like i'm just
gonna move home because it just seemed
so easy but at this point it's been five
years since then and getting a little
bit bored at home and don't know where
else to i can move anywhere typically
technically with my job but i feel
really bad leaving my dad like my dad's
90. that's yeah oh
yeah okay so my dad's 90 he's in really
great shape so he travels a lot
but i feel really bad leaving him and i
would feel super guilty if i like moved
to like new york or texas or las vegas
or anywhere and then something were to
happen to him right it's like i i don't
get those years back i don't get that
time with him back i agree with that so
if i were to move i would move somewhere
like san francisco where i could just
drive back for the weekend if he was
home or i could be at home when he's
home and then the rest of the time i can
just be in the city i agree with that
yeah so tell us when you're making these
tick tock videos how are you coming up
with ideas is there a formula to like
going viral on tick tock i think in the
early days it was it was easier because
there was no finance content right yeah
and as long as i picked a topic that was
somewhat interesting and i had a good
hook and i could hook people into a
story about finances or learning
something about how much a hydroflask
costs that was good enough to go viral i
had a couple good viral hits in 2020 but
i would say since then it's been really
hard what are you noticing now at tik
tok um like how has it changed finance
tick tock or just tick tock in general
both finance tick tock seems like it's
kind of like a content farm like you
just
farm the videos
let's make a skit about
credit utilization and so it's like
hey what's credit utilization
i don't know you tell me and you know i
i think i'm partially to blame for that
because i took that format from another
creator called admoni explains and he's
a great guy and he was making these
business skits back in like april of
2020 i was like oh let me just take that
and simplify it for like broader finance
but now that is like the de facto format
yeah
who created that so i noticed mark
tilbury does it erica kahlberg was the
one who really did it with like the life
hacks really learned that i learned it
from erica can we trace it back like who
was the first to have done like that
sort of because i'm sure it didn't
originate in finance i'm sure it came
from something else it initially came
from like these comedic skits like
people would just make really funny
skits on tick tock and that was like the
trend on tick tock in 2020 just make
these funny skits of you talking to
yourself right and then and money was
really the guy who took it to business
he started to cuss in them he was
explaining like why elon wants to take
over twitter this year for example but
it was all business focused and i think
at that point we had a small finance
tick tock community on like a slack chat
or discord chat or something and uh we
just
were kind of bouncing ideas off of each
other and i was like oh let me try this
skit format i think my first one was
what is a dividend
and that first one did like six million
views off the back man and that whole
summer like from
july to september every skit i made
million views 2 million views 10 million
views like it was just crazy it was
crazy the amount of people that loved it
at the time and how easy it was to
explain a financial concept because it's
so it's so easy to explain a financial
concept when it's conversational so that
did really well but then i would say in
2021 it started to kind of like i
noticed they didn't do as well anymore
and then now this year like after the
life hack stuff erica kohlberg shout out
we like erica i love erica but
it's like everyone's seen that format
now so like it's really hard to
differentiate that format or like i feel
like people scroll and they see the the
the skit format they're like yeah scroll
away yeah it's so interesting on tick
tock just how fast uh trends change and
i feel like something could be in for
like a week and then it's done and it's
played out like you have to find the
next one yeah yes no okay i would say
with finance content it's really topical
so like the topics that do well will
always do well because people want to
hear it again and people have like the
shortest term memory on tick tock like
after two months
you don't even remember what you saw so
like if you saw another one
that's fine but first we gotta thank our
sponsor stash graham i've been saving up
some money recently and i just don't
know what to do with this fast vast cash
stash that i received what the fastcast
vast ass jack i think i think you just
answered it with your your last rhyme
stash stash is a personal finance app
that helps make investing easy and
affordable over 6 million americans
already use it and that's because stash
is super simple and you don't need a lot
of money to start investing and they
even let you buy fractional shares and
that means you're able to invest in
stocks like amazon apple tesla and more
with less than just five dollars and
stash also offers tools like
automatically investing on a set
schedule to help you build good
financial habits which by the way is
something that you should already be
doing if you're watching the channel
stash offers three simple plans starting
at just one dollar a month and seriously
guys getting started with them is a
breeze just download the stash app add
cash to your account and start investing
in your favorite stocks in minutes so
join the more than 6 million people who
know that it's never too early to invest
in yourself and sign up for stash today
and to do that the link is down below in
the description again there's a link
down below in the description to get
started with stash today and guys they
are running a huge promotion if you sign
up with that link they will give you a
50 bonus when you deposit just one
dollar in your account it's a no-brainer
you guys should sign up with that link
down below in the description thank you
so much stash and back to the podcast
so you could remake the same video a few
times
yeah i actually have remade the same
video maybe three or four times okay but
told it somewhat differently change the
words around or maybe use a different
example and it does just as well
sometimes you can even straight repost a
video and it does better the second
thing is seriously i don't really repost
but there are some other financial
creators i've talked to they're like
yeah why don't i just repost i've i've
always i'm not i can't try this but i've
always been curious to take an old video
of mine and just repost it as new yeah
i'm curious how it would do i i just
want to explain jack why are you
laughing man dude curious we talked
about this a while ago i'm just curious
i i just think it's funny it's so lazy
it's like you're cheering it's so hard
not to miss your your upload schedule by
posting something that or even posted
before graham what are you thinking
i'm curious how it'll do it'll only do
well but if it's the same video yes on
youtube if i post the same video and i
have it listed as an old video
uh but i just reposted a year later is
that gonna be recommended against the
old video is youtube gonna know that
it's a re-upload we could try this on
the the grand stance show great video i
always loved it but it's like who makes
more after x amount of years is it the
plumber or the doctor right and i love
that video i watched it such a long time
ago and uh i think that video is
perfectly evergreen it can be posted
whenever and your original
thumbnail was so bad i know and i feel
like the title wasn't that great but
it's decent and you could remake that
exact same video and it could do like
super well that's better for a tick tock
video i'll give you the idea for tick
tock for youtube i couldn't make that
video but basically i came him up with
this like four years ago you know what i
didn't come up with that i think i saw
someone else who did some sort of
comparison between someone who did a
trade versus a physician who had a
higher net worth at the age of like 45
and 50. and the answer was you'd make
more money you'd have a higher net worth
working in the trades than you would
becoming a doctor by the age of like 50
and it wasn't until a person became like
mid-50s did the physician actually make
more money why is that debt debt yeah
student loan debt and the age at which
you really start making money so for a
doctor they didn't really start making
us you know serious income until their
mid-thirties at the very earliest versus
a tradesman uh i tracked the income if
they started working at 18 years old
with no student debt that gave them such
a huge advantage with the compound
interest does that also assume that that
tradesman was making good decisions
investing correct yeah but also that
assumes the doctors as well right so
yeah the doctor could be buying a brand
new seven series bmw to park out side of
the side of the office and like 10
secretaries and yeah you know they could
do a whole bunch of stuff as well for
sure but yeah what about you how's uh
what are you what are you doing on
youtube right now so right now we have
my main channel which went through a bit
of an existential crisis the past three
months i didn't really know what to make
and i kind of wanted to make it more
broad like i wanted to make like broad
business essays but they just didn't
don't do well in the main channel so
what i've done is i've created a second
channel i'm going to post them there
and
the whole reason behind that is that i'm
just still going to keep the main
channel the main channel which is like
personal finance and investing advice
and then on the second channel just kind
of build build this like library of
content that's hopefully bingeable for
that on what's a broad business essay
something like how amazon makes money or
the dark side of casinos it's kind of
like a documentary type thing yeah
you patrick cc'd that it would do so
well yeah so yeah that's the idea is
like okay let's do business essays but
i'm gonna be more in the video so it's
not completely voiceover like i'll be
part of some of the videos so that's
actually why we're here as well is we're
gonna film that video about casinos
tomorrow at the casino what's the video
on casinos it's uh
i think we have two titles the first is
called the the dark side of slot
machines
or it's called how ugly carpets make
casinos massive profits no i don't like
that okay
that's why we got two i don't mind the
ugly carpets because it's really thought
provoking yes so if you could somehow uh
like have like a the classic youtuber
thing right now is a big red arrow
pointed out like a disgusting carpet how
this makes casinos
i probably wouldn't say ugly carpets
this makes casinos
why all casinos have ugly carpets
maybe something like that i don't know
i think this with a big that's just me
that's kind of like the new youtube
style it's the new youtube style
huge red arrow pointing at something
kind of obscure that's thought-provoking
exactly but i actually don't mind that
at all there was a video uh that i saw
that went super viral about how a door
makes some twitch streamer a bunch of
money yeah it was that and that did
extremely well so you could do something
simple it's actually the exact thumbnail
like inspiration i had but just with a
carpet and just like make everything
else black besides the carpet with a
little arrow too yeah but yeah
it's like stuff like that yeah so tell
us about that i mean what's it's not
going to be
jake tran which is all voiceover yeah
but he's he's in at the end so credit
drake transformed at the end but it's
more just like i'm the host and then
like you're going to see me 15 of the
time on camera but then it'll still be
mostly b-roll yeah so tell us about the
dark side of the casino what do you want
to know
what the video is about what the house
always wins the
carpets are distracting so it's like
disorienting there's like four
psychological ways that casinos get you
to stay inside the casino right like
carpets are ugly uh no clocks or windows
they have curving hallways where you
know they don't want you to make a right
hand turn because a right a hard right
turn activates the decision making part
of your brain so like you don't want
that so they all curve and they all have
amaze-like layouts and then we talk
about the business breakdown like the
the revenue breakdown of casino because
it's not all from gambling it's actually
mostly from rooms and entertainment and
and actually uh shopping and like food
and then
yeah it's only 30 of casino profits at
least at mgm that's interesting wait i
thought that they give all the rooms to
the really big high rollers they do but
they still make a lot of money on the
rooms like we paid 340 for our room
tonight for a night on wednesday
so so yeah it's like that and then the
last part of the video is on slot
machines because slot machines actually
make the most money for casinos right
just straight up they make a lot of
money and a lot of people play them
doesn't really make sense why they play
them i think they're boring but some
people love them and
they make like five times as much
revenue for the casino than blackjack or
craps or roulette so yeah that's why
they're everywhere now what about online
casinos
didn't do any research there
that would be the intro that's what i
think they're going to be cracking down
on pretty soon maybe twitch
i would say that make that the next
video the more i'm seeing about uh how
much these twitch streamers are making
from from online casinos it's staggering
staggering millions a month yes yeah per
month yeah so imagine they run their own
casinos yeah two to three million
dollars a month
just to get paid to
gamble uh who was it that turned it down
i think it was mischief who said that he
turned down i think it was like eight
hundred thousand dollars a month and he
only had to stream for 15 hours a month
yeah and then he said that his like uh
he's like but that doesn't mean that
everybody has a prize he's like because
if somebody's paying me like i think he
said 10 million a month he'd take it
yeah something like that oh yeah oh you
know what yeah yeah shamelessly yeah he
said he said it was 10 million dollars a
year oh there it is yeah 10 million
dollars a year was his offer
um or how much he was offered to gamble
for 15 hours a month on twitch on twitch
and it's this weird gray area because
like
technically
they're not breaking a law
but at what point does that influence
children's desire to maybe gamble where
they shouldn't right right yeah i think
what they should do why isn't there like
a website where you could just this
would be a good idea a website that you
could stream just gambling
like just that and you have to enter
like your age or like you know i'm 21
years old yeah you can watch it when
you're only 18. no so you could watch it
if you're i don't know what the if it's
18 or 21 i don't know but like whatever
it is you have to like select i'm 18
years old and this is a website that you
could just watch people gamble you think
people would watch that i do
yeah but then these casinos wouldn't be
offering the streamers which then means
the streamers would stop doing that so
it's like yeah i don't know i think i
mean the value is definitely in their
audience right but uh yeah
would you have a price
if like a casino comes to you and says
50. you could pay me no price to break
your mortgage 50 million dollars a year
i turn down a lot of sponsorships
because
i just don't align with them and really
yeah and it's like i could use the money
but i don't
you know i don't feel like i would not
use the product so if i don't use the
product and i don't feel good about the
product i'm not going to promote it
graham what's your price
oh
everybody's got a price you do get to do
gambling every day
those are for free
man i just love the camera now uh the
options yeah i mean it's a
depends gosh i mean it would it would
have to be so much money that like
right it would probably have to be
probably 10 million a month
guaranteed for a year and i would just
have the disclaimer like guys this is
stupid but but i think my audience would
respect it enough and be like hey
graham's getting paid so much money like
it would be the financially smart move
to take it
so i would i think my audience would
understand and would get like hey that
that's they're overpaying it's a lot of
money we get it uh but it would have to
be guaranteed for a year and guaranteed
that i would not get in trouble because
the last thing i'd want is like legal
trouble or
then it's not worth it like any risk of
any is no yeah but assuming it's fine
for one year one you know 100 million
bucks
i would do the same as graham but i
would make sure because i could never
lead someone in without a disclaimer
right so i would make sure that
somewhere in like the claws or in the
contract or whatever there's a clause
where it's like jack you can say
whatever you want and i'll be like guys
never do this don't touch these casinos
whatever i'm getting paid bank
like that's why i'm doing this but hey
enjoy and you got to have like the
little you know disclaimer that shows on
the bottom of the screen that goes by
yeah like do not do this at home
yeah no we've turned down so like i'd
much rather do that we've turned down
like every nft offer every like we
turned down a lot of crypto oh gosh yeah
i would say 80 of them are just crap and
there's a few that like even get through
like we have an initial like we sift
through them and it's like 90 just go up
even even the remaining 10 there are a
few look and do afterwards i'm just
not a fan i just don't like it i don't
like it so we turn those down but first
we gotta thank our sponsor ftxus hey
guys right now is a great time to buy
crypto and finding a trustworthy and
reputable exchange is not always easy on
top of that it's really important to
find an exchange that saves you money
and ftxus has fees that are up to 85
lower than the top competitors that's
why we recommend if you're gonna start
trading crypto you should do what we do
and use the ftx app we both use the ftx
app because of how simple and easy it is
to use all you got to do is select what
you want to buy type in how much you
want to buy and how often you want to
buy it swipe right and you're done and
best of all when you buy crypto and nfts
on a ton of different exchanges they
usually charge big old fees and how
gross is that nasty i hate that word but
with ftx you can trade as much as you
want all without any fees guys that is
seriously unheard of in the crypto world
to be able to trade without fees it's
amazing yeah plus you could get all the
way up to a hundred dollars of free
crypto and free crypto in every trade
over ten dollars and use the link down
below in the description and make a
deposit guys ftx is soon launching ftx
stocks and they're going to be an
all-in-one inclusive finance app where
you can trade crypto and nfts and stocks
all in one place so start trading crypto
and nfts with no fees whatsoever today
with a link down below in the
description on the ftx app again just
use the link down below in the
description to get started today and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast here's a moral question all
right okay there's a train going by it's
the classic
oh gosh jack i thought we moved on from
this there's a train going by and there
are two kids playing on the train tracks
like 100 yards in front of the train and
there's a really obese person standing
in front of you and you're like on this
balcony above where the train is going
right would you push that obese person
in front of the train they're just obese
for the sake of being you know stopping
the train or whatever not to be
insensitive but just to like stop the
train would you do that
to save the lives of the two people that
are on the tracks
so it's one life for two
see that's a utilitarian moral question
a utilitarian would say yeah push push
that person sure yeah yeah so what would
i do yeah gosh that's so hard what would
you do
i think i answered this yeah
you answer first i'll tell you my answer
why do they have to be obese jack that
no that was just for this okay never
mind i take it back they're not obese
okay they're a person they're an
adorable person yes okay that's normal
they are a human of that is average the
train has a sensor that detects people
once they're hit and they're just a
regular person and if you push this
person over the sensors will go off and
stop the charge
it could be yeah it's no different than
like a saw movie like
i would push them
you would push them one for two
i think i said i wouldn't um because i
would not push that yeah because the the
the train track they're on the train
tracks they shouldn't have been on the
train tracks
[Laughter]
they're playing on the train track they
shouldn't have been doing that it's
tragic but i couldn't
er so it was so like an innocent life i
couldn't do that um the other the other
two were on the train tracks so they
they i guess i was trying to think of it
more in like a vacuum like yeah
let's say they were tied down on the
train track
yeah
oh gosh now they're forced against their
will to be there then would you push
this normal sorry not normal
well it sucks because i wouldn't want to
be the cause of that person's uh demise
you know so it's like
right the other person
uh you know demised the the the two
people on the train tracks tied down
like that's their responsibility but
mine would be
the unaliving of a innocent person what
if the person was like a serial killer i
would push him okay yeah yeah yeah i
probably couldn't do it like i'd
i don't know if i would even like to say
i could but i feel like i couldn't live
with myself if i actually
was responsible for the of someone else
you know personally it's a really tough
question so yeah yeah we don't say the d
word oh sorry unalive unaliveness of
another the demise yeah yeah
so anyway what do you think about uh hey
guys
no no no no
really quick let's talk about i want to
know your thoughts on the tick tock
finance gurus aspect because i think
tick tock has maybe not the best uh
reputation for for some people pumping
stuff or maybe not giving the best
advice and from what i've seen there's
both a lot of good advice but there's a
lot of really bad advice and what are
your thoughts on the stigma of tick-tock
finance i think the stigma is there for
a reason there's probably more bad
actors than there are good actors
obviously if i if i see something that
doesn't really resonate with me and i
think it's bad advice i just ignore it
yeah you know i let them do whatever
they're doing i'm not going to like come
for them in the comments but i would not
recommend that channel to anybody
learning financial advice and so yeah
there's going to be good and bad with
everything just like with youtube like
there's going to be some people on
youtube that are bad actors and trying
to get you to buy whatever the hell that
they're they're buying or selling yeah
so i do think that it's gotten a pretty
bad stigma though because
you know the the videos that do go viral
sometimes they can be really dumb and
they and i just don't feel like that
happens on youtube versus like on tick
tock like some 16 year old thinks that
they can make 50 000 flipping you know
crypto in 24 hours by just getting one
percent a day or something like that you
know something something silly like that
and that could go viral that could get
like two million views
because people are watching like they
re-watch it so i remember when tick tock
banned cryptocurrency for a while they
did and that was for like eight months
they banned financial not banned but
they shadow band like they basically put
a like a kind of like a filtration on
anything finance related so if i
mentioned the word stock market the
video would get no views not no views
but it would get throttled and same
thing with like bank accounts or
i don't know and when was that
i want to say summer of last year so
like may to like august or something
really and as a finance creator how did
that affect the content you were making
uh that was a depressing time the tick
tock in the tick tock life i mean yeah
every video wasn't doing very well so i
just had to reset my expectations for
how how good a video would do
um
i was actually flown down to tick tock
for
like a i guess they just wanted to talk
to some creators and i did tell the ceo
that like directly it's like hey the ceo
of tiktok yeah he's like hey you guys
got some
bad filtration going on bad moderation
and it's because tick tock has a
development team in china
and they're all chinese all the tectonic
developers that are working on the
algorithm for the us product so what
happens is is the us team will give them
feedback but that feedback might get
lost in translation like imagine telling
a developer hey filter out finance
content what is the developer going to
do if they don't know much about finance
content they're just going to take the
keywords and just filter them all
versus like contextually it could be
good advice or bad advice you know you
never know and so there's a big
disconnect in the teams and so i think
that remote that remote work is
is tough and then there's also a
language barrier so like the developers
have to figure out how to do that now i
saw a video i'm not sure if it's uh you
know hocus pocus
but i watched a video on the algorithm
of tiktok and how the us is a lot
different than what it is in china and i
heard in china they're showing very
uplifting videos that are very
motivational that are very educational
and that uh in my opinion make them just
overall better more well-rounded people
versus in the us i scroll tick-tock and
i see the most mind-numbing content that
just dissolves the brain
it's just so bad and just puts you into
this daze of
you zone out and then an hour goes by
and you're just dumb i hate to say it
like dance videos yeah it's just trends
but
it's all really viral content and it's
addicting i mean i'll i'll straight like
every time i go on tick tock if i'm
sitting there like actually scrolling 10
20 minutes and it feels what feels like
a minute yeah but they're all
mind-numbing videos
is do you know if there's any truth
there what do you think i don't know if
there's any truth to that but it could
be also a difference in cultural values
right like
the culture over there that might value
that type of stuff versus what what do
we value in the united states it's tough
to say
i don't know if tiktok is
doing something crazy with their
algorithm in different countries or it's
used as a weapon to make us dumber or
something like that but
i'd like to think that i always like to
think on the optimistic side so like i
give people the better the benefit of
the doubt even companies sometimes and i
think uh sometimes to a fault but i give
people the benefit of the doubt and i
think that
probably the algorithm is just
optimizing for view duration right
because that's all they want yeah to do
is keep you on the platform i think when
you said values it's very true and i
think uh the algorithm is probably so
good that it just gets whatever gets the
most uh watch time clicks uh engagement
and that just happens in the us to be
the content that you know is
mind-numbing it's mind-numbing yeah
think about everyone just wants to zone
out like if you go on tick-tock probably
and i would say the same thing with
youtube probably not as much with
youtube but a lot of for a lot of people
tick-tock is just a way how could i
spend these next five minutes ten
minutes that turns into an hour because
it's just
yeah yeah it's quick content and some
people really enjoy it like i know that
we watch it yeah we're creators and so
sometimes we were watching it with a
critical eye but i have friends who just
watch it and they're laughing the entire
time they're loving it and they're
sending it to their friends and making
memes and and they have a great time
they don't think it's a waste of time
yeah but science is true like like me i
think it's kind of a waste of time to
watch it i'm always like oh i just
watched 20 minutes guys that sucks but
at the same time i don't watch netflix
and some people you know
at the end of the day yeah so it's like
who am i to judge that's true that's
fair right that's fair
it's kind of like the same argument with
video games and i i've had this video
game argument before like people will
come to me like oh why do you play video
games it's like it's just entertainment
it's like what do i like what does it
matter if i choose to play video games
or go watch a movie or go read or
do something and i think there's a
stigma there that video games are not
engaging or good for you but i learned a
lot of my social skills through gaming
growing up and i also learned a lot of
you know typing skills and
commerce skills through you know trading
you know
trading my final fantasy gill and not
getting scams like i haven't been
scammed on crypto yet why because of
video games like i'm really wary i'm
like oh you're trying to scam me like
i'm not gonna fall for this like i've
fallen for this before
hey if you send me a hundred bucks i'll
send you 200 back oh yeah yeah
you know what's that you know what that
sounds like graham this is good this is
going to be way off topic here but okay
uh when i was younger i used to play
this game called the runescape yep yeah
i know exactly what you're talking about
and i was going to go there
so yeah so there's this there was these
people at the marketplace so stanley and
they would be like oh doubling gold
right so you know so and then so what i
would do is i would go up to them i'd be
like well i want you to double like
let's say 500 000 in my gold but you
have to prove it to me first so here's
like 50k like some measly amount and
then uh they would do it because they
think i'm going to give them the big
thing and i would just take their
they reminded me so i was scared
i scammed the scammer this is one of my
favorite videos that i i was showing
this to jack this is like two years ago
you know the scammers in the comments
section that pretend to be you i
remember that video yeah yeah uh so for
those unaware
i i started talking to three of those
scammers and they promised like these
ponzi like returns where if you know i'm
gonna put money in they guarantee it's
gonna be worth a certain amount and so i
put 20 bucks in one to see like how it
works and i told them up front they said
hey i got like 50 000 but i just want to
see like make sure it works first and so
i i gave them 20 bucks and they take you
to this like fake web page where
basically they could type in how much
money is in your account um
and then it grew over time to like 36
dollars like 40 bucks and i said wow
this is great i just want to make sure
that withdrawal works first can you send
me this money back and then i'll send in
like 5 000 or something like that they
legit sent the money back like extra
money extra money
but you did it in real life yeah so i
sent in 20 they sent back 40 and i think
we used your buddy's uh paypal or venmo
so they wouldn't know it's me
and so your buddy actually got the money
and sent it over to me amazing yeah
didn't you didn't you want to still
collect the money
what do you mean the 20 profit yeah
[Laughter]
something like that my buddy got it and
then he sent it back over the ground yes
it was my it was my money to begin with
that's again that's my money 20 iced
coffees yeah
so but yeah it again reminds me of that
so you know as long as you're a step
you're gonna bait him with a little bit
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah oh actually
we uh we never really told this story
afterwards what happened
um
one of the guys
found out about that video after i
posted it the scammer the scammer wow
not the guy who sent me the money but
another one another scammer watched the
video afterwards and then actually got
in contact with me and we talked and it
was after that we talked i wanted to get
him on the second channel
and it was a weird thing because i i
felt 90 he was telling the truth on this
but he gave depictions of like the
working conditions there
he was from i think uganda i think it
was and just the working conditions are
really terrible they're trying to
support their families there's no money
this is one of the only ways that they
could like support their families
and
he basically just said like i don't want
to be doing this right there you know
it's run by the gangs here and if we
don't do it they threaten our families
and this and that so this is why we're
doing it um oh and then he he would only
call me during like certain time like he
said like you cannot text me at all like
it's called he was pretty secretive
about it which made me think that he was
legit
and then i said if you wanted to come on
the second channel and like just expose
this
i'll give all the ad revenue to you yeah
and i will uh set up like i don't know
if we could do a gofundme i don't know
something like maybe he was trying to
scam you and that's why i worried about
that i worry just in case i felt it was
real but i didn't know if i want to
think that part of me thought maybe i
just do it and let the audience decide
if they believe it's fake or real
he never decided to go through with it
and decided to hold off which makes me
think it was real because he was worried
about the safety of his family and like
if he gets outed as like that guy right
um i don't think it's worth it so i have
a feeling it's real that's a tough moral
situation as well for sure yeah and i
couldn't post a video like that right uh
if anything were to ever happen to him
that like that would be my fault and i
couldn't got it do that but overall
seemed like a nice guy
okay so you know so behind all of this
you know behind these people scamming
even though it's annoying
uh the situation there is incredibly
different than the uh i think a lot of
people put ourselves like well i
wouldn't do that but meanwhile you have
access to you know get a job anywhere
and make twenty thousand dollars a year
versus them children that you have to
yeah take care of yeah imagine imagine
that you know the area is run by gangs
right you have three kids at home that
don't have food and like what's your
option it's not like you could bag or
like go work at starbucks or anything
what do you do
you do that because that's the way and
you know and they rationalize it the you
know they're wealthy americans they they
got health care they have roads and
electricity and running water and you
know they could afford it so i could see
that you know so i could see what yeah
so after it gave me it depends on the
situation big perspective on just like
in america or really in in many first
world countries you're very fortunate
so and you kind of forget that uh the
rest of the world is not like that
lesson of the day guys love that listen
thanks so nice you're welcome jack yeah
i think we should also talk about your
income over time oh boy sure that'll
kind of be an interesting journey i
remember you said you initially started
out as a video game customer support
person outside of college yes how much
were you making doing that 40k a year
and you did that for how long uh a year
and a half doing customer support a year
and a half so 40k a year this was
2011 2010 2011. and this was in the
barrier this was in the bay area how'd
you survive on 40k a year in the bay
lived at home well
nothing's
in the changed
rent would have been forty thousand
dollars a year yeah yeah it would be
back then twenty five hundred it was
little it was a little cheaper back then
yeah
the whole tech scene hadn't exploded
quite yet like facebook really started
to explode after 2014 i would say is
when ever like all the developments
started to happen and rent prices
started to go crazy so in 2010 it was
still okay
it was still like manageable but i still
didn't want to move out because i'm only
making 40k a year as a financial advisor
i made like 50k a year so step up a step
up yeah yeah but not by much and then um
even after i was licensed it was still
50k a year and then they wanted me to
get clients in and start making more
through commissions so
mutual funds they've had they have
expense ratios and you know the
financial advisor gets paid a percentage
of of the mutual funds that you sell
it's usually just mutual funds like vu
or vti but but wrapped differently with
a higher expense ratio that you know
someone pays for because they want the
service or they want
someone to guide them through the market
if you will so is that what most
financial advisors do they just find
other like index funds and then kind of
wrap it in a mutual fund s type
yeah and then slap on an expense ratio
but the reason why they can justify
doing that is by finding people and
presenting them to it in a service where
you basically you're the financial
advisor be the person that takes the
action of investing and basically
guaranteeing oh you'll be fine for the
most part right when i was at merrill
lynch i'm not going to speak for all
financial advisors but i would say at
merrill lynch there was one guy who was
doing very well for himself and he says
i don't really manage portfolios i
manage expectations
and so he was just on the phone with
clients all the time managing their
expectations for what the portfolio
should return and that's essentially
what they were doing is kind of like
picking funds you know let's say the
lazy refund portfolio they would just
kind of pick that for a client obviously
you want to tailor it to their risk
tolerance and their time horizon and all
that good stuff
but essentially that was the investing
piece and then they also offered like
planning so like retirement planning
estate planning five to nine plans all
that sort of thing so it was like an
all-in-one service but i would say for
the most part if you're just going to a
financial advisor to invest you'd
probably be better off
doing yourself with like vu or vti or
a robo advisor like wealthfront for
example like be just fine yeah
um and that's what you kind of notice
with like millennials and maybe even
younger is that they're more willing to
do it themselves but i would say the
older generation so like the financial
advisor i think a lot of it is just
calming people down making sure they
don't sell and they keep investing
because i would imagine how many how
many people in 2020 were like we got to
sell everything the market's going down
and then the financial advisor is
telling them no don't worry don't worry
we gotta buy more what do you mean buy
more i bet it was a lot of just you know
the stock market just flipped yeah yeah
i just saw graham's video the stock
market's about to reverse
and they gotta say
you know did you watch the end though he
said buy and hold index funds oh i
didn't make it that far i only looked at
the title thumbnail yeah
yeah so that was that was uh my
financial advisory period and then i
the next gaming company i worked at was
called machine zone and machine zone
created that video game called mobile
strike and game of war they used to have
these super bowl commercials with arnold
schwarzenegger and like kate uh kate
upton you know i remember those yeah and
uh that was a really well-funded company
but i started off doing quality quality
assurance for them so very similar to
customer support i was making like 16
bucks an hour and then i started doing
live ops so live ops is something very
different it's basically optimizing
in-game packages based on the hour to
sell the most revenue possible to the
gamer at that time
and that was paying i think my first
salary was 75k a year so this was now
yeah it was a big step up
and then six months after that it was
like it got increased to 90. and then
six months after that i was making like
120. what exactly were you doing so
imagine like
a mobile video game do you play clash of
clans or i did
candy crush for example they have those
offers that when you first sign in you
can buy a package like an in-game
package of items sure
and that stuff is not just random that's
all bit backed by data analytics by you
know
a b tests by everything that you can
imagine because they want to figure out
what's going to get people to spend the
most amount of money
and so
every hour to have a real-time chart of
the revenue for that company for that
game almost by the minute so it's almost
like looking at your youtube analytics
like you're seeing how many views per
minute are coming in but instead you see
revenue
and so
when you're looking at that you're like
okay
right now this this package that i'm
running on this game is making this this
hour about 100k
let me try to make a package for the
next hour that'll run at the top of the
hour so like let's say it's 12 pm right
now i'll make a package that starts at 1
pm
and i'll try to get people
more enticed to buy that second package
at the same time that package is going
you can run an in-game event to really
incentivize people to buy that first
package or that package that you're
showing yeah and then you can look at
the data analytics for
all the user balances so like oh this
user doesn't have enough coal or this
user doesn't have like the majority of
users don't have enough gen like uh
wood for example just an in-game item
and so then you can sell them the wood
with an event that requires a lot of
wood to beat the event if that makes
sense wow so you're using like username
that's genius so using user balances the
data there then you're crafting a
package that exactly matches that event
and oftentimes the package would have
just enough wood but not enough wood to
finish the event and that was basically
how that company monetized very well oh
my gosh and so i could change these
packages on an hourly basis and uh i was
doing that for like a year straight but
it was a it was almost a 24 7 job how
much were they making at its height i
think we made
one game made 110 million in a month oh
my gosh it was about like three to five
million a day and if it was under three
the ceo at the time would get really
pissed no way
the team started out with just me and
another guy
well actually it was me and like two
other guys my boss and like another guy
at first and then it really started to
expand by the time i left it was a team
of like 20. and almost every mobile
video game company has a live ops team
now
and uh maybe not clash of clans clash of
clans is in finland they do things a
little bit differently they probably
just have one or two guys running it but
a lot of the video games now have like
massive teams because
it makes a big difference in bottom line
but the thing is you have to manage it
24 7.
so
we had like these weird random night
shifts like i have to get up at 4am
sometimes to run the events until like
12
and then then i would go into work and
then i'd stay there all day and it was a
very like uh face time culture like you
wanted to spend a lot of time in there
so that was from 2014 to 2016 and that
time flew by like that like i don't even
remember it like it was so fast did that
not make you want to get into the uh
mobile video game space no it didn't
really feel like real money just like
you know like anything you get get kind
of numb to it and you kind of don't
really put the numbers together but uh
yeah it was a bit i mean it was a big
company it did really well it was valued
at like five to ten billion at one point
it eventually did
come crashing down a little bit and they
got bought and they got bought by
applovin have you heard of that company
app 11
is a mobile game studio and they ipod
like like last year or something like
that two years ago gosh that they get
acquired for they actually got acquired
for like i think like 700 million
dollars so it was worth five to ten
but then like some some macro events
happened like they couldn't get the
funding to like raise at that valuation
then they got acquired for 700 million
after everything was going down
and the initial investors or all the
investors put in 800 million into the
company so it's underwater so all my
stock was worthless after that really
and that hap that happens to a lot of
tech companies where they raise so much
money to scale as quickly as possible
but if they don't get acquired for above
what they raise for then all the common
stockholders aka the employees they get
wiped out yeah cause they gotta pay back
everyone else but yeah they pay off the
debt the debt first so they pay off the
c team to like transition the company
wow
they don't actually pay you know the a
lot of the common stockholders don't get
anything worse you still work there and
in that case
they gave the people that still worked
there the new shares of apple oven so
they did pretty well actually oh my gosh
what do you think led to their downfall
there were a few things i think they
pushed really too hard on monetization
like it was a team that was really
incentivized to make a lot of money and
so if they weren't hitting their revenue
targets based on the investors you know
expectations
the team would push harder and like
basically you can inflate a game what
that means is like if you keep
pumping resources into a game like if i
just make 2 trillion wood in that wood
example then wood becomes valueless
right just like anything so you have to
balance in-game economics with what
you're selling and if like you're just
pumping the because you want to sell
more you just buy you give crazy deals
you can give crazy deals yeah and then
there was one exploit or exploit where
like
users could switch their app country to
like i was gone at this point but users
could switch their app country to like
egypt or something and get a hundred
dollar pack for like 15 bucks
and it was known as like the bug sale or
something like that like it looked like
a bug so like people were buying it wow
but essentially like it was a team with
like bad i guess
incentives yeah to try to hit revenue
and then that bug occurred and they kept
pushing it because they thought it was
making them revenue but it was just
eroding the game oh my god so eventually
that game kind of like slowly falls off
typical mobile
mobile strike
or game of war those typical those
typical games have like a three to five
year life cycle
so after like yeah i i think this also
circles back to ethics like
did it ever feel
weird to
make events that oh like you don't have
enough resources so you gotta buy more
or you know because at that point are
you losing the vision of the game you
know you provide entertainment yeah i
think so
i mean
the games weren't really designed to be
in my opinion fun like i didn't really
have a great time playing them but they
they attracted a really hardcore user
base that was not afraid to spend money
whales and whales make up most of the
revenue of any mobile game right just
like at a casino the top one percent
probably
makes up their entire revenue why does
whales spend so much money uh there's
just like a certain cohort of person so
like if you acquire 100 paid users like
they're gonna pay in the game like the
top one or two percent will spend the
most like they'll make up your entire
revenue stack so like oh it's kind of
like the 80 20 rule yeah 80 percent of
the profits come from 20 of the people
it was like that of whales like there
was one whale
it's like the son of like some sort of
like dubai billionaires i thought you
meant people from wales no
i thought you meant to love most people
jack jack is so adorable jack was like
wow
from whales
that was a jack that was a jack moment
right over my head wow that was like
that's quintessential jack oh my god
holy ghost
yeah
jack in the future
i wouldn't admit that i just roll with
the punches i had to man why you have to
you didn't have to i'm welsh so that's
why oh yeah yeah there you go i'm like
super yeah that explains why you're
spending so much money
so that makes sense mobile games so
there was a son or a daughter of a
billionaire in dubai and she basically
spent like three million dollars in the
game
and she was the biggest whale she just
had so much money i forget what her name
was but then there was also another
really rich billionaire or something in
dubai and you could track their
locations if they allowed it in the app
and this guy would only be at beach
clubs in the mediterranean sea and just
like buying these hundred dollar packs
all day and he spent like a million
dollars too
at that point can you reach out to them
personally and and invite them and be
like hey like they wanted to they did
they're like this guy's great like he's
literally saving ourselves yeah yeah i
would do that i'd fly them out like give
them give them as much wood as they want
to
if you spend a million dollars to get
unlimited everything in the game like it
becomes no longer a challenge anymore
was like the best player in the game
yeah yeah it was a pay-to-win game i
mean
i mean there are some games that are not
pay to win for example league of legends
like you just get skins like you need
skill and there are games that where you
just spend as much money and you become
the most powerful
being in the planet i wonder what she's
thinking now though especially after the
games like falling out of rel
yeah you get bored of it i'm sure she
has so much money
okay that's a fair point oh my god gosh
three million probably running rubid
yeah yeah
family business she made all it back
steak uh yeah so that was my income
trajectory i made 140k my last year
there
and then after that i started my own
business
and then
those two years i probably made 65k each
and then uh
maybe 50k in 2020 but then in you know
in 2021 with youtube and stuff that that
grew a lot so what are we talking i
would say like two hundred two hundred
kids yeah two hundred maybe like if you
add in my investment income it was
probably a little bit more but
yeah
i feel like i could make way more money
if i just did more sponsors
it's something i'm kind of thinking of
tinkering with this year it's like
adding in the right sponsors like i
would still do some sponsorships don't
get me wrong here like i would do some
but i'm not like
for a long time i didn't want to put any
youtube ads in the videos yeah just like
kind of like andre
um
and i think that
as long as the
reason i'm putting the ads in is like or
sorry as long as the sponsor is the same
consistent one over time i'm okay with
that i just don't want to send the wrong
message where i'm like sponsored by
robin hood one day fidelity the next you
know schwab the third day yeah well
that's why they have uh the clauses in
there that says you're exclusive in that
category right you
talked to me about this before this
podcast but you were talking about how
it is to be single
you know yes i am single do you think
that there's any correlation between
living with your father and also being
single maybe subconsciously i think
subconsciously yes i'm uh
yeah i think probably it's in the back
of my mind for sure
i'm also pretty picky and i also
maybe am i'm not good at dating multiple
people at once so like i always had a
hard time like if one person if i was
dating one person like trying to find
other people to date i think what
happens is i get really over invested in
that one person and that's a turn off
right
because i'm just like i'm ready to go
i'm like hey i really like you like
let's let's hang out all the time but
when you're dating you kind of want to
take a little bit slower and you really
just try to like connect with that
person and learn more about them and i
feel like i can't even be myself until
like the fourth date so like a lot of
times i don't even get to the fourth
date
put it that way do you think that it's
usually the girls not reaching out back
to you for the second day or they're
ghosting you or is it you being too
picky so like which side of the uh it's
probably both yeah i've had many my fair
share of like people that don't reach
out after the second day i think the
issue is that it takes you four dates to
open up
i think it takes even three even two is
too much you need to be pretty open on
the first date i think and the cure to
that yeah i just be well not like
nervous or not like
you know or not like uh putting on
a bit more of like a like a facade not a
facade i don't know but but you know
yeah your guard up
going into it just like hey this is me
and i think the cure to that is going on
a lot of dates back to back to back so
and you know what like like you did 30
tick tocks in 30 days 30 days yeah 30
days
in 30 days or even even five a week
monday through friday every night i just
say you know i'm gonna go out to dinner
yeah every night i'd like that and just
be expensive yeah do you want to be the
first first date yeah
yeah yeah but
but here's the thing they'll be i mean i
i don't know how you coordinate that
right realistically but but
you'll get a sense very quickly what
you're looking for and you'll be
the picky one
because you'll know like oh i don't like
when you know people who do this and i
prefer this and i i like that right
you'll know so fast that you know after
the 10th one it'll just be like ugh i
got to do another one of these
and then you're yourself yeah yeah and i
think for me like even on this podcast i
don't really feel 100 authentic
no offense not because you guys but
because the cameras are on and stuff
like that like even on my own channel
it's like really hard to like for me to
show the real my real self the
personality a little bit yeah yeah and i
think i like especially on a date you
know i'm like i'm trying to be as
positive as i can be i'm like pretty
optimistic but it really takes a long
time to get to know somebody i don't
think you need to be positive i think
you just embrace however you feel you're
having a bad day i'm having a bad day
got a headache right now but today here
i am
yeah my steak's undercooked but uh
that's something i would say though like
hey like i'm really sorry 10 out of 10.
i mean i do you're not single then man
because i know well macy and macy knows
that she knows if i walk in she's like
yeah is it a 10 i'm like yeah i was a 10
today
is there anything i could do i'm like no
again i did title thumbnail i tried i
could do to solve the way i'm feeling no
there's nothing
nothing you could do it's ruined
throw into all of it right no no i'm
kidding
yeah all right i'll try it i'll try that
next time and one thing that's helped me
out with my confidence a little bit at
least is the abundance mentality so like
of course i find myself the more dates i
go on even if i'm not having a great
time or i don't mesh very well with the
person i'm like okay you know what i've
been on let's say three dates in the
past three weeks that's an abundance
right and it definitely helps in my
confidence which helps my personality
shine through a little bit more but i
have the same issue that you do it's
really hard to act yourself with someone
that you're it's kind of like
performative right you kind of have to
be like yeah the perfect person
and then the more experience you have
the less anxious you feel yeah so yeah
that's where i'm at yeah with that yeah
are you what tinder bumble hinge uh i
had hinge for a while i've kind of like
stopped it just because it it was giving
me more anxiety than like having it on
that make sense yeah like i was always
like nervous about it or i check it too
much i get kind of distracted do you
ever get people like recognizing you and
they'd be like whoa i got my stock
advice yes that does happen i think that
actually led to me getting like a video
date once during the pandemic but then
she got on the date and she was just
like tell me about being a tick talker
like i just wanted to match with you to
oh gosh that was a tick tock that would
upset me yeah i know oh my god king
charles cavalier too i was so excited
i was already thinking about my future
with them but you know oh my god yeah
but but yeah but so yeah that does
happen um yeah
but i think it's still a net net
positive thing like yeah it's like
reputable and people google you and
you're like oh okay like he's like a
normal human being and they can see what
you look like on video so like it's a
little it's helpful yeah i don't think
it's a downside thing but no no
yeah good stuff yeah and that same stuff
happens to me there was this girl that
i've been dming with for a while now
probably like two weeks and it was
actually pretty lengthy messages
and she her instagram profile is private
but she did have a gallery right like a
link in her bio and i tapped it and
she's a model and i was like looking at
the photos everything like dang this
girl's very pretty and we were talking a
lot right like a lot yeah and then uh i
finally send the follow request and she
accepts it second photo down it's like
around her boyfriend
she's talking about how much he she
loves him and i'm like we've been
talking for like a while now in fairness
was she talking like in a flirtatious
way wow
do you tell the boyfriend this i mean
i'm just gonna you gotta leave
sometimes that happens you know what i
mean or are you just too good looking i
don't know well i don't think she was in
it for that but okay but yeah and shady
i know shady crazy stuff out there do
you have people reach out to you because
you work with graham for example all the
time yeah well actually i wouldn't say
all the time but a decent amount yeah
people will be like hey man i got this
question can graham answer this question
or whatever i mean i mean women do women
reach out to you to date because they're
like oh graham i think people reach out
to me for jack believe oh yeah all right
but
i don't yeah i don't want to throw
anyone under the bus but uh that's funny
not the
best options
oh are you talking about graham posted
on his instagram one time he wanted me
to go on a date with someone uh and he
didn't specify the gender
okay so no that's i wasn't even talking
about that but you go ahead okay
yeah he posted on his instagram because
we had this idea to bring a first date
on the podcast and we could talk to this
person right this girl idea i remember
you had like this
the episode where he had like three
women blindfolded or he was blind oh
this is before way before this is like
the first one we just started the
podcast yeah one idea was yeah let's get
dave yeah we wanted to do get jack a
tinder date on the podcast got it uh but
we felt on tinder it's we
jack wasn't having good luck getting
someone from tinder on the pod like and
going over to stranger's house
yeah but i posted on instagram and i i
think i showed a picture of you like
anyone like looking for a date yeah and
turns out he got a lot of swipes swipes
ups right a lot like nice it was
probably up for 15 or so minutes and he
maybe got 20 or so wow yeah all dudes
not a single girl
so he didn't specify in posting if i'm
looking for women
but i i was and i still am
so okay
yeah no the other one was uh someone who
became very persistent
uh wanted to to
go on a date with jack and messaged me
and said she she messaged jack and jack
wasn't getting back to her so she
messaged me and then i brought her up to
jack and i looked and i said jack she
seems kind of normal
and uh you might want to you know reach
out and jack was like no i'll do it i'll
do it jack never reached out but it was
just the incessant just like hey what's
going on what's going on like like just
the follow-ups got too much like a
follow-up a week later like fine but
when it was like she multiplied
multiple follow-ups and then i'm like
wow if she's if she's sending me
messages and i'm not responding and she
sent me like
five or six in a few days like that's
too much
all right jack dodged a bullet there
okay too much it seems like you've got a
lot of options out here too vegas we're
working on it yeah
yeah yeah cool
yeah i'm rethinking this whole thing now
with jack i'm thinking it's better he's
single there's more time to work
his focus is gonna be uh but he just
plays ping-pong yeah i'm not the type
like graham i think is the type where he
finds someone he invests himself all the
way in it i'm very much not that person
interesting i don't fall in love quickly
i find someone and i like them and then
we become friends first and we're
friends for a while but i also don't
really want to spend like so much time
with this person like my last girlfriend
i probably hung out with her
three two to two times a week maybe i
think that's and that was like what
she's doing that was high school
no that was college that was college
yeah that was like three months of high
school and then two oh that's right you
know you're right you're right yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so one thing you brought
up before this podcast was that you have
a chunk of change you're sitting yeah
here's how you're investing yeah yeah so
i have enough for a down payment on a
house in the bay
and that's just sitting in cash and i
you know i have a good chunk invested in
the market as well that's just kind of
i'm still dca into that
but i don't know what to do i don't know
if i should buy an investment property i
don't know if i should buy a
single-family home to live in myself you
know i live in my dad's house
or should i just go rent somewhere in
this in san francisco and just try to
continue to build my income with youtube
and tick tock and all that stuff kind of
just holding because i don't really know
what's going to happen to the economy
and
i think we'll know a lot more in six
months especially with
uh you know you know how like the first
inflation report in november of 2021 was
like six percent or something yeah i
think in november of 2022 we'll have
that one year data of like okay how has
inflation been for the past from 2021 to
2022 when it really started to ramp up
and that's when i think we'll have we'll
know a lot more
about interest rates
inflation the economy what's going to
happen
interesting so why so are you set on
moving out you're going to move out
either way i think so i think so this
summer 100
yes okay i would say it's probably
better for you to rent than buy
something up there i think when you look
at the values in the bay area yeah
renting almost always makes more sense
unless you're buying and planning to
keep this house for the rest of your
life it's probably in the short term
renting is better also gives you a lot
more mobility where in the future if you
want to up and leave or go travel just
do whatever you're not going to be stuck
and saddled with a house that you're
going to have to rent out that probably
is not going to cash flow
so i'd say you're better off renting yep
good mobility uh and plus your income
income's gonna fluctuate so much for
these next like five ten years yeah i'd
rent um as far as the rest of the money
do you wanna be a landlord um not really
no i know you're a landlord how do you
like it
uh
it was great in the beginning now i yeah
i have property manager if i could i
mean i don't want to see if i could snap
my fingers and just be done with it all
but
right now at this point in time i want
nothing to do and just like my brain my
capacity is filled and so like yeah
anything at this point now i'm gonna
have to like i know i forget things just
because i have no more space so like
something is forgotten
um but yeah the properties
in comparison to everything else right
now they make very little in terms of
the percentage right so it's just it's a
mental drain but they're all rented
thankfully and you know it's good enough
yeah but just thinking like uh you know
i'm i'm making sure the property taxes
are due and i get a notice in the mail
about like
insurance coming like i'm the one who
deals yeah deal with it it's those
little things that add up little things
that add up uh so
actually the one i've enjoyed so far was
i invested in a syndicate with brandon
turner
and uh in a mobile home park and he
takes care of everything that's good and
i loved that because it's like a stalk
that you know he's doing all the work
and i just it's kind of like a reit
right in essence but uh you know it's a
syndicate where i'm involved
at least on the in investors side i'd
like that so far i mean i wouldn't dump
everything into that
but um
you know i i value simplicity so much
right now and that's why i've just like
the index funds and that's why i say for
you at this point in time when you're so
busy at least with index funds
it's so you don't have to do anything
you don't have to stress if the market
goes down it's an index fund it's like
the whole market goes down it's not just
you like you're not doing anything wrong
that's what i like about index funds
yeah the other thing i want to bring up
was that my chunk of change can buy
a very crappy place in the bay area
right it can buy like
a condo oh you know a one bedroom little
mini thing that i would never live in
for like the rest of my life i live in
in it for like a year maybe but or it's
going to be a big figure upper right
like yeah how much how much cash are you
talking about here
oh like half a mil oh yeah i would say
just dollar dollar cost hours yeah yeah
i would say i have a hundred thousand
dollars in cash at all times just
sitting in a high yield saving and then
the other 400 that's just dollar cost
okay thanks so simple i'd rent
good mobility yeah yeah most likely
there's no sense in you buying something
like that um
i would say when you're ready to settle
down yeah uh you know
maybe have a family or something like
that and you know where you want to live
and you're like this is where i want to
live for that 15 years then buy okay but
until then yeah i think mobility very
important fair enough what about you
jack what do you think for you yeah do
you agree with graham's comments yeah i
agree with graham i think you shouldn't
be totally closed off to the idea of
being a landlord
but also
i wouldn't consider buying too much
right now
so i think right yeah i would say just
dollar cost averaging to an index fund
would probably just be the most ideal
thing but also when you are sitting on
that cash that is invested yeah always
you know if you are considering being a
landlord just like studying some deals
when did you close in your house jack
october 11th october 11 2021 last year
kind of interesting that was almost near
the peak of the market
your house is a your house is a libra
that wasn't it the market has still gone
up so i bought my house just under six
hundred thousand dollars and the
zestimate
[Laughter]
says it's like i don't know six seven
years ago
but i'm just but i'm just saying it's
it's odd you know because the stock
market peaked in november of 2021 so
it's kind of weird that you know jack
buys and then yeah 30 days later the
market peaks i'm just saying
i'm just saying hey you know yeah when
you sold robin hood
it pops the next day like an hour later
so is he the character is that what
you're trying to say or yeah are you
saying i should just empty everything
into the stock market right now
if you want it to crash if i want the
world to end oh yeah yeah oh wait empty
you mean like sell off all your
investors
like put all of my money all of my cash
now in the stock in the stock market
it's gonna crash yeah please don't check
but if you if you pull out all your
money out of the stock market it'll go
up yeah yeah well we'll see what happens
with that yeah we tested the robinhood
theory i've been wanting to test this
for the longest time and it proves to be
true
part of me wants to see like jack has to
investigate like a series he can't just
like you know here's a hundred bucks
like it's gotta be considerable money
i've already lost so much money on
robinhood man
it's like that was my contribution okay
there was the case study how about this
can we do a test i think this would be
really fun uh
we'll probably have to do a midweek
we'll probably have to do midweek
i want i i'd say you invest ten thousand
dollars into and we'll just do a one
month or like you know one week or
something like that ten thousand dollars
into
something and then we track it the next
week just to see if it's up or down from
the day you bought it
and we're gonna put the theory to that
now it's 10 grand so chances are in a
week
plus or minus 10 percent i mean the very
most and that's like a gen that would be
a crazy week you don't know that man it
could be 40 for all i know man i have a
question for a gram yeah what's your
five ten year plan here no no clown no
clue no i know i want to do the podcast
um
one year plan is to continue at the same
trajectory as i have been so three main
channels a week there are three main
videos on the main channel we've talked
about this before but my original goal
was to go down to two videos a week in
the main channel
and i became i i was so used to doing
three yeah oh yeah eventually go down
two
but then i but then every week i did
three i'm like yeah i got an extra video
out yeah and got an extra video it feels
good yeah and so i i wanna now continue
that throughout this year because now
everything for me is like oh it's a
bonus and an extra video and i'm still
doing it um i want to continue because i
know building up this but i would i
would not be able to build up the
momentum again i think i've worked so
hard to build up that stamina for three
videos a week as soon as i go to two i'm
never gonna be able to go to the gym
right what do you think about the future
do you think the podcast could be a
really scalable format for you like five
years down the line yeah i would use it
one day i could see myself putting like
80 of the effort in the podcast and
treating the podcast as they did the
main channel like not that i don't treat
the podcast uh you know well but it's
just my my focus has always been main
channel first before anything like that
was that still oh my my biggest focus is
that everything else is secondary to
that main channel but at some point i
could see that switching
i don't know when
um
but i'm getting better now if i i think
there's been maybe two two times this
year where i've uh not posted
and on the main on the main channel i
think in terms of like three times a
week so i missed two episodes
uh and i think i
it's easy for me like before i'd have
panic attacks so like i'm missing an
episode it was like i would
i i wouldn't miss an episode i know how
like yeah yeah so i wouldn't uh but
there was
you know what it was on a holiday i
remember this it was on a labor day
labor day
i didn't post that day even though i had
a video ready because it was a holiday
and just the amount of nerves i had be
like oh my gosh i post on friday my next
video is not going to post until
wednesday it was it freaked out so i
never missed a video so uh but yeah i
missed two and i didn't feel bad about
it
so
it i'm moving in that direction but i'm
still you know i want to post my three
okay i like that jack what do you think
of his plan i think it's a fantastic
plan i think you should go all in on the
podcast
uh no i i like his playing a lot i think
it makes sense one thing that is a
little concerning
is when he says oh i'll never be able to
go back up to three and when he does
describe things as like for things such
as forgetting certain things because he
feels like his
his brain's capacity is already
full that sounds like burn out to me
very clearly and i'm worried that
you are still sprinting and it's just
straight into a wall well no so what
happened is that i've taken on too many
obligations i've i've said you have a
lot of stuff yeah i've said yes to every
opera not every opportunity i've said
yes to almost every opportunity that's
good and these are great opportunities
and i've said yes to them because i'm
like i'd be stupid to turn this down and
like i don't know how long it's going to
last for this opportunity opportunities
here i'm gonna take it like creator
properties with ryan pineda correct um i
mean there's been a whole bunch of them
they're all good
um
but i think mentally i have space for
like three even though ten of them are
like
home runs but like i could focus
mentally on so many things and there's
like three of them so i think i said yes
to too many things and that really
affected me so like i've been slowly
working on scaling back
um i've been slowly cutting things not
because they're bad but just because
it's like mentally
low roi no not even it's just
it's it's more of just a mental drain
like some of these things are really
high roi yeah i think the brain only has
a finite amount of space right so like
if you're if you're thinking about roi
on a in a vacuum yeah
you know the mentorship group probably
makes you x amount of dollars but if
it's taking up that mental space that
mental space can't be used for something
else yeah and it's a higher roi because
i do look at every hour of my day i'm
like this hour is worth that this amount
of money and i calculate that like
everything i do per hour
that that is the opportunity cost so if
i go and have a coffee with someone in
the afternoon that's a very expensive
coffee so like i gotta prioritize
everything else and like if i take an
hour off it's not just that hour it
takes me three hours to get back back
down too i know exactly so it's uh
yeah even i forget what it was um and
i've started looking at this
if if i answer a text even though that
text might be just a simple thing then
i'm waiting for that person to respond
back to that text i'm keeping an eye on
it
it like takes my focus away even just a
little bit
and that little bit of focus
it takes me 30 minutes to get back to
where i was in that like zone
uh yeah the zone to get into the flow
state the flow station when i'm i'm in
the flow state for like four hours five
hours of the day during certain hours
and anything that takes away from that i
just i can't do it so that's why what
are you doing so rigid
scripting or planning planning planning
yeah and then i could only film before 9
pm because after 9 i get tired
yeah i can see that yeah and it doesn't
it's not as energetic and not as fun so
certain filming times for certain
planning times
so yeah i'm the same way i gotta film
like
usually afternoon that's when i film
yeah like for between 12 and three yeah
that's when i'm the most energetic yeah
i found my best filming times are
usually four to eight p.m ah right now
evenings yeah it's right now
yeah it's right now early mornings it's
too like i feel groggy throughout my
eyes just like uh
okay fair well i think it's a good i
think it's a cool plan yeah
i would love to see you guys do more
more podcast stuff like or just double
down on podcast stuff yeah i think
there's only so much we could do on the
podcast because you don't you can't
oversaturate
um
so right now oh we just started doing
this this so when this posts this we'll
already be doing this but we're going to
twice a week on the podcast so once once
every sunday and then once every
wednesday okay yeah cool
so i don't know if we could do more than
that realistically without like
overshadowing without over doing it so i
i'd say i guess you would focus on like
higher quality
people yes i think so so i think getting
celebrities or something yeah we we
definitely want to grow the roster of
guests we would love to get into like tv
actors
it's interesting though the downside
with a lot of those people though is
that they have pr teams right and
they're so strict they don't want them
going on it's a liability they come on
the iced coffee hour they talk about
something it's like hey it's bad
uh gets them in trouble
so uh
yeah it's it's a lot more easy to get
someone on um
youtube to come on and talk about this
what are the repercussions nothing yeah
so okay but yeah that's our goal so if
you're watching this by the way and you
have any recommendations or you have a
connection to someone who you think
would be amazing on the ice coffee hour
uh we'll link to all the information
down below in the description where you
could either submit an application or uh
yeah make the connection we would love
that i think you should do like
professional golfers man there's so many
that live
in las vegas because of that tpc that's
over here and they make a lot of money
as we're getting like deeper into this
we're starting to realize more it's like
not as easy as just getting a cool guest
on they have to fit this like this mold
of just like what we'll do well
and what comes across on camera because
especially with with i don't say a lot
of athletes but you know they're really
good at that sport but when you put them
in front of a camera speaking
it's just
you you really have to like
pull information out or it's it's you
know you want it to be exciting so i
think some of the best guests that we've
had
houston
uh he runs royalty exotics you put him
in front of a camera oh my gosh he
lights up yeah like he's more talkative
and like tells better stories on camera
uh he's so good and then um brandon
turner brandon turner is another great
example and alex romozzi
those are people you put in front of a
camera and they just
bloom and it's it's so good like we
don't even need to talk yeah yeah that's
what i love about alex for mostly he
just like he just talks i'd be like go
yeah that was a really great episode
yeah yeah yeah uh houston's the same way
you just talk
and he'll he'll do the entire podcast
himself
that's so good just
listen no no we just we just listen we
just listen yeah i guess i could talk
more and then we then it's always just
be like wait what do you say oh my gosh
oh my god oh my god oh my gosh this is
jack oh my gosh yeah you'll get at least
one of those and then it's me how much
was it oh my gosh
you want me to bring up uh a story sure
okay go the first time i was on the
graham stefan show yeah which was when i
called in on tick tock i was actually a
little bit disappointed after
i felt a little sad because i felt like
i looked up to graham for so long and
you know i finally got on the podcast
and i felt like the call was pretty
short and just for the video and then
like we didn't get to chat afterwards
and i felt like we could maybe talk
about this because this is it probably
was a parasocial relationship on my side
right but i felt like you know this is
the guy i looked up to for so long and
he was very short with me not that you
were short with me but like you were
just doing it for the for the show and
then boom hang up right and you know i
was just starting to make youtube videos
and i at that moment i remember being
like so disheartened and like so sad oh
man okay so i wanted to bring that up
and confront great yeah i'm glad you did
that yeah but also but also to let you
know that now
i don't think that you meant any harm by
that and i know
you a little bit more personally now
especially after we met at that carrot
event and i felt like oh like this is
yeah he's totally normal it was just
like he's busy and like his time is
worth
is valuable so like i could see why yeah
did we not talk because usually after
every call there's like a few minutes
afterwards do we not no we didn't no you
didn't do that usually yeah no oh you
would just say you it would be before
the call a little bit oh that was like a
minute you know what it was jack would
line up three to four calls at a time
and we would do them 9 9 20 9 40 10. got
it and we had to set these strict
deadlines uh because otherwise um
because we had scheduled calls with
these people yeah yeah that was the
difficult part with those calls is
because sometimes if we would run over
on one the other person would be
unavailable on the next one right and so
if they went over a certain time we
missed the next one which then pushed
the next one back and pretty soon we're
on like the third call i'm texting
jacqueline hey man we got to move it to
like one yeah because you guys did
text me and say hey i'll be like 10
minutes late i remember being like okay
that's that's fine yeah so that's
probably what happened yes i'm just
letting you know oh man i told all my
friends about it and i was like yeah
like grant wasn't that nice i never
considered that that people could
develop like you said parasocial
relationships with graham the barbies
calls yeah never thought about iced
coffee hours yeah we just figured they
just wanted to call in and ask questions
oh yeah yeah well i think maybe as like
a creator you know especially one on
tick tock and like
didn't really find my footing on youtube
yet like that's really i was like hoping
for a little bit of like mentorship or
like hey you should try this or
you know like you'll run into this
problem yeah and like just avoid this
and so
but that was then god no i'm sorry yeah
i remember back then yeah scheduling
them back to back was difficult it's
like
that's what made it where you had to
like end at a certain time and
immediately afterwards we'd call another
person were you there in person jack
because you were yes some of these you
you were there
yeah and jack would be like looking at
the time and texting the next yeah we're
gonna be five minutes late uh and then
texting the person after that being like
hey we're gonna be this time i think you
were texting me probably yeah for
context on the graham stefan show in the
beginning some of the first style of
videos that we did was people would call
in graham would provide funny not
for entertainment purposes only they
weren't paying for it that was a big
thing too for these people and he would
just talk them through whatever
financial or relationships sometimes
problems that they had and we'd post
those and you were someone that called
in a very long time ago very true yeah i
just want to say like now being on a
creator on on the creator side we get a
lot of requests it's like the dms are
full all day with a bunch of questions
and i try to get to as many as i can but
now i kind of know like
maybe where you were coming from yeah it
totally makes sense like yeah any other
you know issues you have with graham
yeah bringing we may as well bring out
all the issues yeah oh the coffee was
actually
very good okay it was very good you got
to say it's really good now for sale
bankruptcy.com yes how is that doing is
that still not doing okay i mean we're
not doing it for
we're not doing it for money i mean at
this at this point like at the very
beginning prices were significantly
lower they're like 25 lower than they
are now oh my god uh yeah and it's our
fault like yes we could raise prices but
uh you know
and we did a little bit like we had to
we raised prices enough to cover our own
customer that we're not a loss it's
doing just fine
but it's not something that we do for
money
does it sell well without you shouting
it out correct i mean does it sell
pretty good without you shouting yes oh
it does yeah it does yeah it's it's
doing if i
so i've
don't really shout it out um i have it
as the banner below
below the main channel videos you have
that like youtube thing uh it's there it
does about
two to seven hundred dollars a day
that's great in sales consistently wow
um we have a 55 returning customer rate
which is really really really high
um
and they get a discount too if they do
the subscription so if i think it's like
15 10 or 15 off if they agree to the
subscription shipping like once a week
or once a month or whatever so a lot of
people have done that for the discount
um that's great for us too because at
least we could kind of predict like
where the next sales are going to be but
it's good and then if i do a shout out
like and i'm talking like a main channel
video yeah we'll do anywhere between 50
and 100 grand of of sales so i usually
have to give them a heads up and like
yeah hey i'm doing an update on this
let's make sure we have enough have you
noticed like every time you shout
something out the efficacy goes down or
no no but i've only shouted it out like
three times or four times in the last
two years
so it's rare but and usually those
videos are more about like
not making money still
it's interesting i i find it and people
love it the coffee for me uh the best
thing is the branding because everyone
is like you know bankroll coffee
no one asked yo how's your rental
properties doing yeah nobody cares how's
the coffee because it's something that
anyone could buy
at any price point they could get it
well here's what i enjoy it about the
you know how i asked you the efficacy of
the shoutout yeah well eventually i
don't want to do that many sponsorships
because what if one day i want to create
a business on top of my youtube business
where every time i shout out i can just
get free customer acquisition right do
you think it not it doesn't matter so
now i don't load up the sponsors yeah it
doesn't matter because you got to think
to every video there's going to be a
significant portion of them that have
not seen your previous videos and are
brand new and so every time i post a
video you could see just like the new
viewers who have never seen me before
it's shocking that when i post a video
it's like i'll say what's up graham it's
guys here and they're like and people
are like you made a mistake and i'm like
i've been saying this for like two years
but they've either not watched the
previous videos they're brand new and so
that's why sometimes like you have to
repeat certain topics because you're
reaching a new audience that hasn't seen
the old ones have you noticed your new
audience are your new members declining
or are they still growing like your new
audience coming to you growing but not
as fast as 2020 like 2020 i think was
this 2020 2021 was an anomaly year i
think january of 21 i gained 180 000
subscribers in one month and that was
new uh that was because of gamestop and
dogecoin
um
and that's brought so many new people
into into the investing space now is
like we're entering a time of what
should be normal
2020 just like exploded yeah and so just
like you see the tech companies going up
like 400 you saw that on the finance
channels what do you think about like
dead subs because like you definitely
have some subs that don't watch you
anymore right like they're just inactive
what's your opinion on that how do you
get them back
is there any way to get them back
i don't focus on that yeah i mean i
would focus on the people that watch the
content and even for me i subscribe to
channels that i saw like five years ago
and i don't really watch them but yeah
it's the occasional video every now and
then i'll see some what do they post
click on it and then watch it
very few channels i'll watch every
single video very few you worry about
the view to subscriber ratio no i don't
think about it okay now for finance it's
different than you know like matthew
beam or mr correct correct yeah yeah
ryan finance i would say having a 10 10
to 15
view to subscriber asia is really good
okay
less than
eight percent and it's bad probably bad
i usually aim for about
ten percent that's about for me you feel
bad when you put on an evergreen video
and it's like a ten out of ten no
because because they know what's going
on yeah so like those are the only tens
that are good like all right
yeah i posted a credit card video and it
was so bad like it was a 10 out of 10 of
like of all the tens that was the 10.
if they did that but that means your
next 10 and your next nine won't be tens
i agree that i do tell well
i count some of those as like a nine is
still at ten yeah uh but we'll see what
the credit card video is um now it is a
it's a three
congrats so yeah it's a three oh it's
it's a while to be a two so you could
see just how much it underperformed in
the very beginning oh yeah significantly
yeah way below the curve
uh but but i've gained 3 500 subscribers
from that video which is a lot usually
i'll post a video and i'll gain that's
what i've noticed 400 to 1500 a video
sometimes 2 000 3 500 on this and yeah
so for my channel i don't have a lot of
those i mean i have some evergreens like
that but maybe i should post more of
those just to get more of a stable
adsense revenue coming in because i
don't really make that much on youtube
yeah not a bad idea
yeah okay evergreens yeah i would do
that uh the other evergreen stuff the
other one that was really bad for me was
this how to get a perfect credit score
for zero dollars that was a ten out of
ten and it became a five
and it's still gaining about 3 200 views
every other day search volume mostly and
that's gained 3 000 subscribers so for
me the credit card videos believe it or
not get the most subscribers and high
cpm in high cpm because the people that
watch those videos have to search for
them like they're the ones how to get a
credit score like that's exactly what
they wanted all right let's load up the
credit card videos on the channel they
do so you know it's been a while since
i've done a credit card video how about
uh cards for like certain people like
gen z millennials would you do that no
two news yeah i did the best credit
cards for millennials my worst
performing video of the credit cards
so it's just better to do top five
credit cards 2022 correct updated and
it's gonna do so bad up front but i
think long term will be fine i would do
that i would do um i loved your
metaverse video by the way
thanks he wrote that did you really yeah
he wrote most of it are you serious yeah
it was his first one it was a banger i
loved it yeah and the title came from
brian young because it was very click
bait yeah i felt really bad about that
and i also this is something i want to
talk about i don't want to become a
stock picker on youtube like that's not
how i was taught to invest
and i definitely dca still into the
index funds and i felt like that video
was a poor representation of my channel
maybe not the first half where i talk
about the metaverse but the second half
where we talked about the etf and the
two investments
it's the equivalent of like the gambling
stuff
you know
yeah yeah
i i i watched that video too i liked it
okay like i think there's an audience
for people who want to uh to try their
luck and are just looking for a point in
the right direction
i yeah i wouldn't like for me i wouldn't
make those videos but i do see the
appeal because i watch those videos even
though i don't buy them
pushing them to buy the stock i was just
like if you are interested try this out
i think but still that's i think it's
thought provoking
as long as you go in and be like hey
listen i'm not doing this i'm buying
index funds but if you're interested
these are this is a point in the right
direction these are the kind i i thought
it was so interesting how they're
involved in this and just the
development of the metaverse i loved
your video like i i liked it i saw a lot
of other metaverse videos after that and
i was like yeah interesting yeah yeah
so amp andre mind yeah how to be a
metaverse millionaire in a year my plan
to be and that was really something like
that i have no qualms with that like i
don't care i would continue uh okay but
you had but it's whatever's trending and
at the time the metaverse was like
really trending yeah if there's another
subject that comes up at some point
i don't see any problems with that as
long as you're up front okay yeah thanks
appreciate that i still probably will go
away from the stock picking thing but
yeah as long as you say that you are
just dollar cost averaging and index
funds and stuff but this is some other
stuff you learned on the side that's
fine but you're also noticing as the
stock market's been plummeting there has
been like disproportionately a lot of
negative attention going towards those
who have suggested in individual stocks
whereas graham since he's always
only shield index funds is completely
fine during this that makes sense so
yeah it goes two ways when everything's
going up i'm the idiot and when
everything's going down i'm a genius
yeah so yeah okay
fair mm-hmm humphrey thank you so much
for coming on i really appreciate it and
uh glad you enjoyed the coffee loved it
and you got to get your free stock down
below in the description when you sign
up for public using the gram
have you done that yet i think i yeah i
think i've done that okay guys guys go
check out ftx our beloved sponsor of
this episode
uh they're great guys no fees whatsoever
85 percent less than the comments
when they do what
when they sign up using our link down
below in the description depending on
how much you trade right cool yeah
that's probably on instagram guys
thank you so much and until next time
see you guys later